[Music]
influencers are storytellers when you
look closely everything in our world is
made up of content
[Music]
is a garlic farmer and a youtuber
youtuber i first opened a youtube
channel while looking for ways to help
build trust with customers who purchase
my garlic by showing where it comes from
the reality of rural korea is that we
can no longer find the answer by just
farming
i think that in the end all farmers must
develop their own brand increase their
brand value and become an influencer in
order to survive and grow
he's also a student at daegu cyber
university which launched the country's
first department of influencer
studies i'm taking six courses at the
university on influencer marketing
branding planning and communication i'm
trying to apply the skills i'm learning
to my content
courses in digital marketing and
communications are taking off globally
as platforms like instagram and youtube
take a central role in influencer
culture
duke university's full credit course
building global audiences better known
as the tiktok class teaches undergrads
how to optimize their presence on social
media apps
korea's daegu cyber university says it
aims to cultivate content-based media
influencers and industry experts
our students include those who want to
build their careers in multi-channel
networks or multi-platform networks
based on their understanding of
influencers some people are coming from
the advertising industry trying to
produce quality content with influencers
more efficiently
45 students enrolled in the first
semester of its four-year curriculum the
university has been working with the
provincial government and conglomerates
like cj e m for the past five years to
develop global influencers
yoast company all blanc is a team of
fitness influencers creating a range of
content from home workouts to vlogs and
even expanding into e-commerce
we're a group of people receiving
instant feedback from the public we need
to sometimes create viral content that
satisfies the advertiser and gets likes
and comments from viewers
to date it's got over 1.8 million
subscribers on youtube
we are on a lot of different channels
from youtube to tick tock instagram and
a chinese video platform
yo says each platform under his company
generates over forty thousand dollars of
monthly profit
so our channel is called dkdktv and we
mostly cover k content including k-pop
k-culture k-food k-dramas and everything
about korea basically
with his partner danny kim he explains
the cultural context behind k-pop music
videos and lyrics and offers a korean
perspective for the global audience
his channel garners 10 to 20 000
per month
our main mission is to bridge the
cultural disparity or gap between korea
and the world
globally in 2020 the size of the global
influencer marketing industry was
estimated at 9.3 billion
among them korea made up about 17 which
is very high it's become such a powerful
market
in 2021 hashtag south korea gained 40
million total engagements across all
social media platforms up from 33
million in
2020 influencers like kim are now
expanding their business beyond creating
content
we're trying to expand our brand to
e-commerce nowadays so we established a
company called naked soul where we
curate authentic korean products and
ship them to the global audience
still experts say the influencer
industry is very new voicing the need
for caution and regulation
[Music]
the importance of the influencer market
is growing and the industry itself is
growing rapidly but it's not yet been
systematically established yet i think
it's necessary to have a balance system
that can protect consumers while
activating the market so that the
influencer market can function properly
[Music]
i used to be really introverted but i
think my personality has changed a lot
as i continue to tell stories and create
content
influencers are storytellers using their
stories to attract and move people into
digital spaces
[Music]
you